hi there it's steve here uh the linguist
on language
uh i haven't done a video for quite a
while because i've been traveling um
with my wife uh 40th anniversary as i
said earlier
uh we were in portugal which was lovely
the people are so friendly and and
polite and it's just a it's just a sense
of richness being with those people and
and seeing the old towns and the culture
that they have and the food and the good
wine and it was great and now we're in
spain which is a little more dramatic
the people are not as
as polite and gentle they're a little
rougher
but they still are friendly and you
still have that sense of participating
in in another people's culture and space
we were in gerena which is well first of
all we visited catheres which is an old
medieval town in extremadura which was
phenomenal
just a sense of being
you know 800 years back in history then
we were in gerena which is a quiet
whitewashed
but very affluent and clean little town
in southern spain
near the border with andalucia
now we're in seville which is just a
groveling ant heap of uh
humanity i mean you just have this it's
so human you've got uh
you know old churches and people running
their markets out of them and building
into them and there's the streets are
full of people all the time and they
don't really make eye contact but they
don't run into you either and
it just moves and people are forever
sitting down and having
sandwiches drinking tea coffee drinking
wine eating
tapas of different kinds and it's little
shops and it's just
humanity and you know the net streets
are so narrow the woman who's ironing
in her balcony or bedroom or whatever
can just about touch the person across
the street who might be uh whatever
she's doing so it's a lot of fun
and it kind of brings me to
so when i'm here i'm motivated uh my
wife and i visited merida and we saw
some of the roman ruins there and people
were living in those roman ruins up
until 1972 so that they're just kind of
it's all part of their life there's a
continuity and i thought to myself jesus
i'm motivated to learn latin it's kind
of a pity
that that there's this dis
continuation between
the roman period and then
obviously there were the busy gods and
the arabs and everybody that came here
and then there it picks up again
uh but it really does go back to the
roman origins of people here and it's a
pity that the spanish is in latin so i
said to myself yeah we should have latin
at link
by the same token we visited the
wonderful phenomenal uh arabic
you know castles architecture here in
seville and so then you know much more
than the pictures we see every day of
terror you know terrorists or suicide
bombers you see that delicate
artistic culture and it was not just art
it was science it was medicine it was
agriculture that they had here in
southern spain far more advanced than
the
people in the rest of europe and so then
you're motivated to learn arabic
and of course while i'm here i'm i'm
totally into my spanish i i wish i could
take more books home i bought books i
bought this one here on the history of
spain which i'm reading and i even wrote
some notes on the back to help me
get through my
video and talk about the things that i
want to talk about
and really i want to talk about
motivation because i get emails from
people saying you know should we have a
four month old child should we hire a
spanish-speaking maid or should we put
our child in chinese immersion that age
you know while they're in the womb or
something
so that's one parent this people who are
tremendously stressed about how they
really want to help their kids learn a
second language
now i am quite sure that despite this
tremendous apparent interest in language
learning
nothing much is going to change most
these people are americans and most
americans will not learn other languages
not in the next 20 years that's point
number one so all of this
you know creating pressure on those
parents and on the kids to me is a waste
of time
uh
and unnecessary may not be a waste of
time but it's unnecessary
uh the second thing that struck me i was
in braga and i visited with the
professor there of languages at the mino
university language school and he was of
german origin or maybe austrian i don't
know which and he was lamenting the fact
that nowadays
language students are only interested in
spanish and chinese well english spanish
and chinese period no other languages
and i often get emails from people
saying you know
what's the point learning french do you
think there's a point in learning french
and so again i always answer it depends
on your motivation every language is
worth it and i think it's a pity if
if we try to reduce language learning
down to some kind of utilitarian
my kid has to have chinese because the
chinese economy is going to be so
dominant so i want my chinese my son or
daughter to have a better chance
uh
no
it's gotta come down to motivation
and then i was you know contemplating
because i always visit bookstores i go
to the bookstore here and the language
section in the spanish bookstores is the
same as in every other bookstore the
bulk of the books there have to do with
grammar
passing standard tests cambridge or
toefl or whatever it might be
and often like and then they had a book
here on you know in the spanish learning
section they had
phonetics spanish phonetics
intermediate a
uh intermediate b like how can you
possibly divide
the phonetics or the pronunciation of a
language into this beginner intermediate
and advanced
that's not how it works it's just a
gradual process
of introducing the language if you are
motivated to learn it and if you have
the attitude
which i referred to in one of my uh
videos as this this cultural
weightlessness that you can see yourself
as spanish here you are in in
you know sevilla you want to be spanish
you're in beijing you want to be chinese
if you have that ability to get outside
your own culture and if you're motivated
to learn the language the other stuff
just falls into place
and the more we put
these dry books of grammar in front of
people and say here's the rule get it
right
uh here's how you pronounce the diagrams
of the mouth and pick out 10 words that
begin with p and say them over and over
and all this kind of stuff
we are in fact
uh reducing the motivation in my opinion
now a very motivated person will learn
despite that
but people who aren't so very motivated
should be given more enjoyable ways of
learning the language as i as i always
say
so i'm just saying that the brain needs
motivation the brain needs to be
encouraged needs to be stimulated needs
to find new things
and in that regard too
you know there's always this discussion
between the crash and purists on the one
hand and the grammar teachers on the
other and i knocked the grammar teachers
a lot but the crashing purists say that
all you need to do is read and if you
get books or whatever reading material
that has only a small percentage of new
words each time that you'll graduate or
in the language yeah but you have to
read so much
in order to to get there with that sort
of very small increment of new words
that i'm not in favor of that and so i
say motivated be motivated by what
interests you and if there are more than
a few words you don't know not a problem
read them on the internet where you have
access to
uh
tools like online dictionaries i won't
mention link but that's also too
and
i do believe despite the krashenites and
whatever other proof they have that
when you
do study words that you have selected
from your own listening and reading
and when you try to produce the language
after when you're ready for it and you
get things wrong and you're corrected it
helps you notice and there are a lot of
things that happen in the language that
we don't notice
so
motivation by all means but also a
certain amount of attention to what's
happening happening in the language
and
yeah that was that the other thing i
wanted to mention that came up while i
was traveling was this whole uh issue of
uh of this canadian language portal that
was put up
you know i don't know what it cost them
to do that it's a canadian government
thing money is not an object
a bunch of information about language
learning again the language
establishment
shoving itself in the face of say under
the guise that they're trying to help
people learn languages they advertise
there's this
course that course and these translators
and these interpreters here we are the
canadian language industry that's not
what it's all about language learning is
about
motivation
here i am in spain i'm very motivated to
learn my spanish
and i would add too that the biggest
advantage in going to a country like
portugal or spain where i have been
is not that you're going to speak a lot
of spanish or portuguese because you
won't you know you buy a beer you have a
tapas you might find someone to talk
with you're listening to the radio or
whatever read the newspaper but mostly
it's stimulus and the big reason to go
to a country and expose yourself to the
culture is that it stimulates you to
learn but the learning you still have to
do it on your own and it's primarily an
input process
and if you go to my blog the linguist on
language you'll see a little piece that
i did on the principles
of input-based input-based language
learning and i better stop thanks for
listening